みんなはどれだけ人生のうちで
立ったことがあるかい？
おっと。下ネタじゃねーぞ
下ネタじゃねーぞ
人生でどれだけの時間立っている
いや。や、下ネタに聞こえちゃうな…足です。
人生のうちでどれだけこう、
二本の足で立つことに時間を使っているでしょうか
まあ、小学校の時には宿題もよく忘れたし
終業式とか始業式とかもう
校長先生の話が長い学校だった
だからかなり長い時間立っていると思っています。
そこで今日～は俺様のね
俺様の立つ強さというものを
みんなに見せてやろうと思う。んー。
ズバリ
立ち時間チャレンジ
88888888
はあーーーーーー。
またとんでもないことを思いついてしまった。
立ち時間チャレンジ！
簡単に言うとどれだけ長い時間
立ってられるかというチャレンジでございます。
まあ、俺ぐらいの天才的な足の脚力の
もしのじになるとですね
ちょう、日本語おかしい。
まあー俺ぐらいの天才的な足の脚力の持ち主になると
立つこと位はもうな。余裕なんだよ。朝飯前。
3日と15時間とかもうそうゆうレベルでずっと立っていると思うので
今回はちょっと長い動画になっちまうぞ
みんな退屈させてごめんな（ウインク）
両手はなるべく太ももにこうくっつけておきます。
水分補給はしても良いでしょう。ただし
むやみな水分補給は減点の対象になります。
また、反則の恐れがありますのでももに両手をつけた状態で競技に臨んでください。
足は90°に、ここは90°に開いておいてください。
これが基本的な状態です
まずトイレは先に行っといてください頻尿の方申し訳ございません
トイレに行った時点で失格です
どれだけ廊下で立ってなさいと言われたことか
どれだけ卒業式始業式あの部活のあの変な入賞の
あの、なに、第1位県大会出場おめでとうとか
賞状渡すのどれだけ立って見てたことか
校長先生どれだけ長い話聞いてたことか
コンビニのバイト9時間入ったときずっと立ってた
新幹線4時間ずっと立って待ってた
そういうのの積み重ねが今の俺のこの立つ力を作ったんだよ
負ける気がしねーよ
もう、本気で立つから
はい、あと1分後です。1分後スタートです
2日間は行きたいね。2日間は立ち続けます
2日45、48時間は立ち続けたいっすね
よし…3・2・1、はいスタートです。とぅる、OKです。スタートです（天国と地獄）
ここから僕の立ち…時間チャレンジが始まったわけです
あ、別に暇なわけじゃないよ
12時からスタートしたので…どれだけ立っているかここで一目瞭然だと思います。よろしくお願いしゃっす。
あー…
キツイな
（ふはー）
お、来たんじゃね、来てる。お、来た、やった
おしっ！！1時間行きました。1時間、行きました
（鼻をすする音）馬鹿か。なんで家で一人立ちっぱなしなの
まあ、ちょいけるとこまで行ってみましょう
(鼻をすする）
う～。
なんかねー、腰。腰と頭痛と足がカチカチで関節的な痛みも感じてきました。
もう死にそうです。助けてください
なんで俺こんなことしているのだろう。そう、自分のためさ。
見せてやるぜ～俺の武士道しっ
今まで俺を助けてくれたみんなの顔を思い出す
そいつ達のためなら俺は
どんな苦しいことだって乗切る
そう…自分のためには…
この俺を…
ここまで…
（鼻をすする）
こっこの
（深呼吸をする）
頑張れ…目標を超えろ
2時間だ
決めたことはやり通せ
男だろ
かかとと膝が超絶痛いです
あと眠い
これあの…あれです
あの…
やばいきついです
僕はー
あと少しで
2時間だが
僕はー
このゲームをやって
ふと思った
何の意味が
あるのかということを
うわーー痛って…あー、すーっ
わー、いてててて
2時間ちょいなんでよかったら、挑戦してみてね～
2時間棒立ちで時間を無駄にした男だな、あっ痛っ